- Hi everyone, welcome to the
Daily Homeroom livestream.
We're doing it a little
bit earlier than normal
'cause we have a guest that
we really wanted to talk to
who was available (chuckles)
earlier than normal.
First of all, for those of you wondering,
this new location,
they are cutting down trees
outside of my normal location,
and my kids are getting a little bit loud
downstairs as well.
Before we get into the conversation,
I will make the announcement
that I always make
reminding folks that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
We only exist because we have support
from folks like yourself.
Special call-out to several corporations
who have stepped up in
the last several months,
especially when they found out
we were running at a deficit,
and we were trying to step
up for the COVID response
and our costs went up.
So special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
Fastly, AT&T, and Novartis.
So with that, I am excited to
jump into our conversation.
We have Bill Lewis today,
someone who I've known for some time
and have always enjoyed our conversations.
And I think there's a lot of
things going on in the world
that I would love to get
Bill's perspective on.
So Bill, great to have you.
- My pleasure, great
to be here, thank you.
- So I guess just to introduce you,
you're the co-chairman of Lazard,
a very well-respected
investment bank on Wall Street.
And, you know, I think
given your background
there's many things we
can talk about today.
You know, there's the economy.
There's obviously what's
going on in America
around race relations and policing,
but maybe a good place to start is
tell us a little bit about your journey.
Did you always think
that you would one day
become co-chair of Lazard?
(Bill laughing)
- Yes, no.
Look, I know we don't have a lot of time,
and in my estimation, you're right.
There are a lot of
things we can talk about.
I guess I've got, is this good, yeah.
I guess there are a lot of
things that we can talk about.
I hope we spend a fair amount of time
talking about race in
America because I think
we have not seen anything
like this since 1968.
But that's probably a good
place for me to start.
I grew up in Richmond, Virginia,
the capital of the confederacy.
I went to segregated schools in Richmond
for the first eight years,
actually nine years,
kindergarten through the eighth grade.
As most people know, Brown v.
Board of Education was decided
by the Supreme Court in 1954,
and Richmond really didn't
comply with that until 1970,
so 16 years later.
In 1970, the journey that I'm on now
really took a different turn.
I received a full scholarship
through an organization
called A Better Chance, ABC,
to go off to boarding school
and I went to Philips Academy
in Andover, Massachusetts for four years.
And after Andover I
went to Harvard College
majoring in economics, and
then I went to Wall Street
where I started at Morgan Stanley
in a two-year analyst program.
And then I went to
Harvard Business School,
and then I came back to Morgan Stanley.
I spent 24 years at Morgan Stanley,
ultimately running their
global banking business.
And then I joined Lazard,
where I've been for the last 16 years.
So that's sort of one part of the journey.
Along the way, I've been involved
in lots of not-for-profits,
many around education.
I sat on the board of
Andover for 16 years.
I now sit on the board of
Uncommon Charter Schools,
the largest charter in the Northeast.
I sit on the board of
the Posse Foundation.
the Research Alliance
for New York City Public Schools.
I'm about to go on the board
of the Foundation for Child Development,
and most recently, I joined
the board of The City Fund,
an organization that has been founded
by Reed Hastings and John Arnold.
In addition, I sit on the board
of the New York City Police Foundation
which is an interesting
contrast to the organization
that I co-chaired some time ago
called the Legal Defense Fund,
which is actually an organization
that was started by Thurgood Marshall.
So I've sort of gone full
circle in that regard.
And I sit on the board of the
New York Presbyterian Hospital
which has become the
largest hospital system
dealing with COVID in the United States.
So in a nutshell, that
has been my journey.
That is how I'm spending
my time these days
in addition to talking to
CEOs on a regular basis.
I can't hear you.
- Sorry, I had muted it
'cause my five-year-old
was screaming downstairs
so I didn't wanna, but no I was saying,
no, I think that's really
helpful for people to appreciate
just the breadth of your
perspective that you've had
especially in some of these
organizations you're now on.
Maybe getting straight
to the moment we're in,
you know, you mentioned that
we haven't seen something
like this since 1968.
What do you think it is about now
that is different maybe,
or that everything is
culminating to a head?
And what do you think
this moment will mean?
- I think not to be flip,
but we really have Steve Jobs to thank
in terms of why this moment
is different, the iPhone.
We saw two terrible incidents,
two very different incidents
that were captured on videotape,
but two very powerful incidents.
Obviously, the callous
murder of George Floyd
by the police officer in
Minneapolis was different.
I don't think any of us, or
certainly not a lot of us
have ever seen someone killed
on live television.
I don't care who you are, where you are,
that was a moment in time.
That was a modern-day lynching.
And that has touched a
nerve unlike anything else
that we've seen in this country.
The second incident that
was captured on video
was the scene at Central Park,
which is literally right
across the street from me.
That in a lot of ways
was just as powerful,
not to downplay the
significance of a murder.
But there was an African
American man who went to Harvard
like I did, like my son does
now, my youngest son does now.
That was a man who was
talking very peacefully
and very respectively to a
woman who was violating our laws
here in New York,
and there was a woman
who is known figuratively
by virtually everybody in New York City,
everybody in the world of finance.
This was a 40-year-old
well-educated, highly educated woman
who works for, who worked for
a major financial institution.
So this was a person that
all of us metaphorically
deal with every day.
And she was very thoughtful;
it was all premeditated.
She told this African American
man what she was going to do,
how she was going to lie
and weaponize race, if you will.
Watching those two videos
made us all realize
in very different ways that
we are in a moment in time
that we need to stop and
take stock of who we are
and what we're trying to
accomplish as a country,
and why not a lot has changed
since 1968 when we last had
very very violent social
unrest in our country.
- And I think that is really possible.
You know, we were all aware
of all of the different things
that have been happening
over the last several weeks
or months or frankly years,
but I think kind of the
bookend of those two issues
'cause I think that's right.
That second one, it didn't
result in someone's death,
but it very transparently
showed that people,
people that we would expect
much better of frankly,
that they were in many ways, I mean,
just to add context to it, this is a woman
who's threatening to call the police,
and she knew that in kind
of this he said she said,
she would get the benefit of the doubt.
And if she told the police
that he was threatening her
that it could be a scary thing for him.
What do you think, you
know, to your point,
having everyone having smartphones,
it sheds some light on this,
but obviously for every
incident that is recorded,
there's probably another
hundred that don't get recorded.
How do you think this plays out?
Like, so the first step
is to be able to recognize
it is happening, to have
documentation, and so we are there.
Where do you think this goes?
What are the reforms that
you think need to happen?
And some of them could be legal reform.
Is it something in how
policemen are trained?
But there's other things that
I guess you can only describe
as cultural reform.
So,
how do you think it plays
out or should play out?
- So Sal, that's a great question,
and let me sort of ramble a bit.
First of all, let me
say that I don't think,
and I could be naive and
I could be proven wrong,
I don't think for every one incident
that is captured on video there
are a hundred that are not
because that would suggest
that we've only seen 1%
of the sort of violence
and indifference that exists.
And I don't think our country is that bad,
but I take your point.
We are not, almost by definition,
we can't possibly see and know
everything that is going on.
And even as we saw in the case
of the jogger in Georgia being murdered,
even when there is video,
there's no guarantee
that we're gonna see it.
So look, I think
in terms of framing where we go from here,
I think there will be
several versions of actions,
of a transformation of our society.
And I'm not a big tech person.
Witness how difficult it was
for me to dial into your call.
But what we saw, and in some cases
what we are seeing,
is what I call version 1.0 of a reckoning.
And that is how leading institutions,
whether they're colleges,
high schools, businesses,
political offices, are all putting out
statements of support and acknowledgement
that this time is different,
and our voices must be heard.
And that is a bare minimum.
You look at every professional
sports organization
in this country.
I think 31 or 32
NFL football teams have
put out statements,
and so forth and so on.
So version 1.0
largely revolves around words.
Version 2.0 which is also underway
involves checking the box
around monetary donations,
encouraging employees to give
to their favorite charity
that could addresses some of these issues
with companies matching those donations.
Version 3.0 involves
really substantial
financial contributions.
Morgan Stanley, where I
worked for a long time,
sent a $5 million check over
to the Legal Defense Fund,
Thurgood's organization, last week,
and we're gonna see a lot more of that.
Bank of America announced
that it's gonna spend
a billion dollars on doing this.
But ultimately version
4.0 is gonna involve
more than simply writing checks,
and more than speaking words.
It's gonna involve taking substantive
transformative action around change,
and it's gonna have to be
something that can be measured.
I will make a small wager to anybody
that in one year's time,
every media outlet,
every television station,
streaming service, every newspaper,
will have a highly promoted
feature program,
and it'll be some version
of the following title.
Memorial Day 2021, the
one-year anniversary
of the death, the murder of
George Floyd, what has changed.
And I can guarantee you that
everybody will look back
and ask what has changed,
and I think forward-thinking leaders
will start thinking about that now.
The one thing that the business community
does extremely well,
probably better than any other
institution in our country,
and that is we measure
stuff; we measure everything.
If it's important to us, we measure it.
If it's important to us,
we hold people accountable.
If people sort of accomplish their goals
and do what we have set up to measure,
then they get rewarded.
They get promoted; they get
paid; they get rewarded.
If they don't, then
they're dealt with as well.
They get fired, they get
demoted, or what have you.
And so the business
community is already having
some soul-searching discussions
around what are we gonna measure,
and how are we gonna look
different a year from now?
What will be our contribution
to continuing the dialogs
that have started?
I should have said also that
even before version 1.0,
the most basic thing that has to happen
before we can go anywhere
will be honest conversations
and getting out of your comfort zone.
I have told all my partners at Lazard,
there are only three African
American partners at Lazard,
the rest are white; I've
told every single one of them
that they need to go
through their contacts
and identify seven to 10
African Americans whom they know.
They may know 'em well;
they may not know 'em well.
They may have been high school classmates.
They may see 'em occasionally
in church or somewhere,
but they need to call them,
and they just need to listen
and hear and try to understand
what is going on in this moment in time.
It's a very very uncomfortable
conversation to have.
It's probably not uncomfortable
for the first two or three people you call
because you've known them for a long time,
but to try to reach out to somebody
that you haven talked
to in 10 or 15 years,
and say, "Tell me what you're
experiencing right now"
is something that I think should be
a required moral exercise for
everybody in this country.
And by the way, I'm in turn reaching out
to the hundreds and hundreds of people
that I have interacted with,
the thousands of people
that I have interacted with
over my lifetime to say,
"I'm calling you because I know
"you're thinking about these issues,
"and I know you're
wondering what can you do."
- And it's super helpful
if we imagine ourselves
a year in the future, and you know,
we're having this conversation again.
I agree with you, there
probably will be shows
to that nature.
We're getting questions
off of Facebook and YouTube
on, you know, what are the levers
that hopefully will change by then.
You know, Maya Balaraman says,
"What are your thoughts
on people reacting to this
"in the other extreme, defunding police?"
Actually, Susana Garcia
Dominguez is asking that,
and obviously you have a relationship
with some of the police
groups inside of New York.
Obviously, emotions are
running very high right now,
but what are the levers that
you would like to see changed
a year from now or two years
from now or 10 years from now?
- Well, first of all,
let's just talk a minute
about defunding the police.
I think unfortunately, excuse
me, that's a charged word.
I think people need to appreciate
that by default,
our police departments have been asked
to do a lot of things.
And fundamentally, our police are here
to protect and to serve us,
but our police are not social workers,
and our police are not healthcare workers.
Early in New York City,
we asked our police
to enforce social distancing.
And that's a charged word, enforce.
Police aren't trained to
enforce social distancing.
And so if you look at the budgets
of the police department,
and you look at some of the things
that police have been asked to do,
so for instance, a lot was made
of us shutting down our subway system
for the first time in a hundred plus years
in order to clean it every night
between the hours of one o'clock
and five 'clock in the morning.
Police were asked to go into the subway
to assist the homeless
and to remove the homeless
in order to disinfect those trains.
It's questionable as to whether or not
that's a job for the police.
What the police decided
to do was to take nurses
into the subway stations with them,
and homeless advocates with them
to figure out what to do
with the homeless people
in the subway stations.
That is money that the
police department is spending
on services that
fundamentally aren't policing.
And so when we say defunding,
what we're really talking
about, what I think people
are talking about is reallocating money
that has been parked with
the police department
to cover a whole range of services
that aren't policing in their orientation.
By the way, as an analogy as well,
the largest part of the
New York City budget
is on education.
We spend $30 billion
of our $90 billion budget on education.
But we do a lot more in our
public schools than educate.
We serve more meals in the
New York City public schools
than any other institution
other than the U.S. military.
So we are a huge provider of food.
We provide, in effect, shelter.
We provide daycare,
and so one could argue
that those funds should really
be under health and welfare,
housing or what have you.
So I don't think
defunding in and of itself
of the police department
or the education department
is what we're talking about.
We're really talking
about allowing the police
to do what they're supposed to do
in a smart and intelligent
and thoughtful way,
in a respectful way.
Now having said that,
there are very very very specific
things that should be addressed
as they relate to policing reform.
The current head of the Legal Defense Fund
is a woman named Sherrilyn
Ifill, I-f-I-l-l.
She just wrote a very detailed article
in "Slate" magazine.
It's about three days' old.
She lists probably 15
very specific and reasonable reforms
for our nation's police department.
I would encourage everybody
to read those reforms.
They've very sensible.
They are in the best
interests of our country.
If you ask what should
change within the next year,
I would start there because
those are actionable items,
and acting on those items will tell us
what side are you on.
And not acting on those
items similarly will tell us
what side are you on.
- That's super valuable, and you know,
is the nature of that,
I'm definitely gonna take a
look at that right after this,
is it the nature of it is
things like improving training?
Is it things like maybe be
it'd easier for a sheriff
to let someone go who's
under disciplinary action,
things like that?
- You start with the most
sensible and the most basic.
There should be a database,
a national database
on all law enforcement officials.
If you get fired for
killing somebody illegally
in New York City by using a chokehold,
you shouldn't be able
to go across the river
and get rehired in Newark, New Jersey.
Right now, there's no way for us to track
those kind of offenses
on a nationwide basis.
That's a huge loophole
in the enforcement of civil rights
and dealing with injustices.
We have something in New York
that's called Section 50A.
It revolves around
disclosing certain information,
certain disciplinary
information on all cops.
Right now, that is private information.
Many cities make that information public.
We are talking about training.
We are talking about deescalation.
I like to say that every cop
should wake up every morning,
and before he or she brushes his teeth
should repeat the word
deescalation 10 times.
That should be the mantra.
The vast vast majority of encounters
between the police and our citizens
should result in some
sort of deescalation.
And New York City spends a lot of time
training its officers
on how to deescalate.
And by the way,
deescalation is much easier
when the police officer looks
very much like the community
in which he's policing.
And so it looks very different
when the police officer
does not look like the community
in which he is policing.
Police officers are meant to
be guardians, not warriors.
And that is sort of a
critical part of our training.
And I don't have the list in front of me,
and I haven't committed it to memory
which I probably should,
but I would just advise
people to just pull it up.
You could easily pull it up online.
- That's super helpful,
and we have some questions here,
where Maximilien Bissonnette,
about, well, they're asking for a question
around systemic racism,
a lesson on systemic
racism on Khan Academy.
But this term systemic racism
is something we're hearing a lot of now.
How do you think that
manifests itself in this?
And it's obviously broader
than this notion of policing,
'cause a lot of what
you just described are
kind of it seems very pragmatic policies
to have better accountability,
better transparency, better
training for police officers.
You know, the whole deescalation
thing makes a lot of sense,
but that still doesn't seem to
necessarily get at the heart
of potentially, you know, systemic racism,
and how systemic racism,
and it depends on how you define it,
it pervades more of society.
What does that term mean to
you and how do you get at that?
- What we saw
in the case of the Central Park birder
was systemic racism.
I am sure that that 40-year-old graduate
of the University of Chicago
living in one of the
most liberal communities
in the United States, the
Upper West Side of Manhattan,
working at one of the highest profiled
financial services company in the world
exposed on a regular basis
to a very very diverse
community and population,
very very thoughtfully
announced in advance
how she was gonna lie
to the police department
about what was unfolding in
that park in broad daylight.
By the way,
that could've resulted in a death
of that African American man
because if the police had shown up
and it was sort of his
word against her word,
and if he had done anything,
moved his hand very
quickly or what have you,
he could've been dead.
That is the raw definition
of systemic racism.
And Sal, I don't know
how we deal with that
until we have had
an ongoing and sustained
national conversation around race.
And I know the people like Bryan Stevenson
at the Equal Justice Institute
and Darren Walker at the Ford Foundation
are trying to facilitate that.
But in this moment in time,
I think we are talking
about a series,
an ongoing series of discussions
around racism
and how did we get here.
Coming back to what you do so well,
and that is education,
I think there is a huge opportunity,
a huge, a must-do,
for us to think about
how we put this topic
into our classrooms early.
How do we instruct our teachers
to have this discussion
with four-year-olds and
five-year-olds and six-year-olds?
We are amazingly creative and thoughtful
about using technology
and the like to solve
some really really really
tough education questions.
I think that we're gonna have to think
really really differently about
how we get the discussion,
and how we get exercises
and how we teach
the whole concept of systemic racism.
I don't know.
I don't have an answer for that,
but I would say
that I believe the vast
majority of parents
were shocked when they heard the videotape
of the woman in Central Park,
and I believe that the
vast majority of parents
would be appalled
if they knew that they had friends
who could talk like that,
or God forbid, their children
could talk like this.
And so I pose this as a real opportunity
and a real challenge for our educators.
Can't hear, I can't hear you (laughs).
- Sorry, no, my bad, my kids are making
a ridiculous amount of noise downstairs.
They're just playing
the piano and screaming.
Anyway, this is
- Call the police (laughs)!
- what you get
working from home (laughs).
I've threatened it.
My five-year-old is under the impression
that the police are,
and this goes maybe to
your previous point,
maybe the police are invoked
a little bit too much,
but I've definitely
threatened him sometimes.
I guess maybe some final words,
there's obviously a lot of people
with a lot of energy right now around it.
I like this idea of the
very tangible things
mentioned in the "Slate" article,
and I think our team has just
put the link to that article
in the message boards
on Facebook and YouTube
for everyone to look at it,
but what should happen to the
energy around the protests?
There is a world where they say,
"Hey, here are the five
reforms we need to see."
There's a world where they're saying
we're just gonna keep doing it
'cause people need to see it.
You know, there might be
elements in the protests
of even also economic
anger or displacement
that are mixed in with
the systemic racism.
How do you think the
protests are gonna evolve,
and what advice would you have
for the people who are on the streets?
How should that evolve?
- Excuse me, we had
massive protests, civil
unrest in the early '60s,
and that led to the Voting Rights Act
and the Civil Rights Act,
one in 1964 and one in 1965.
The immediate result of these protests
should lead to people coming
out to vote in November
and making changes from top to the bottom.
People chose not to vote in 2016
for any number of reasons,
and there were consequences to not voting.
The most basic right that we all have
and the most basic
obligation that we all have
is to translate protest into action,
and the most basic action that we can take
revolves around voting,
and voting at the federal level,
voting at the state level,
and voting at the local level.
The voices are there unlike any
that most of the people on
this call have every seen.
And the will is there.
And the vast vast vast
majority of the protesters
in excess of probably 99%,
are protesting peacefully,
and they need to continue
this peaceful protest
right up through election day in November.
The other thing that
people around the country
should be doing is
going to visit en masse
their police chief and their mayors
and demanding an answer
to the following question:
how can we be assured that
what happened in Minneapolis
will never happen in our city?
It could be a city of 10,000 people.
It could be a city of 100,000 people,
but people need to get into
the nitty gritty and understand
if what they saw happening in Minneapolis
could happen in their hometown.
But I think, Sal, the most important thing
that everybody can do
is translate protest into voting.
The business community will
be doing a lot of things.
And I'm sure the not-for-profit world
will be doing a lot of things,
and the education community
will be doing a lot of things.
They will all be very very different.
But the one thing that we
can all do which is identical
and it is a requirement, it is a right,
it is an obligation, is to vote.
- Yeah, no, I think those are
very actionable doable things
for anyone listening.
Well, Bill, whenever these conversations,
and I learned a lot in
the last 25 to 30 minutes
that we've had to chat,
and I know a lot of the folks
watching on YouTube and
Facebook have as well.
It's always, you know,
I think you have a gift
for kind of cutting through
issues quite incisively.
So thank you for that,
and I hope we can do this again,
especially as our world
continues to evolve.
I really appreciate this conversation.
- It's been my pleasure.
I guess I've got a question.
I didn't realize we were
on YouTube or Facebook.
How do I send that to my kids (laughs)?
- (laughs) We'll send
you the link for sure!
My apologies if I didn't tell you
that we've been live
for the last 25 minutes,
but you've been doing great!
- Yeah, I knew it was
live; I just didn't know
what it was live to, so I
appreciate that (laughs).
- Okay, okay, well you know,
sometimes the best conversations
are the ones where you don't think
- Yeah.
- there's a lot of folks watching.
But no, from the feedback
on Facebook and YouTube,
I think a lot of people
have really appreciated your thoughts.
And I think, you know, it's interesting
'cause we've been hearing about this
almost continuously on the
news for several weeks now,
but a lot of what you said
in the last 20 to 30 minutes,
you know, it kinda sparked
some ahas in my mind,
and I don't think I'm alone.
And it was very actionable and tangible
which I think is really
really valuable right now,
so I appreciate that.
- Well, I enjoyed it.
Thank you very much for having me.
- Thanks so much, Bill.
- Okay, take care.
- So thanks everyone for joining today.
I don't know if you heard some of my kids
screaming downstairs,
my apologies for that,
but we're keeping it real here.
And they were cutting trees
outside of my other place I am,
so that's why I'm in the
noisier place right now.
But, you know, if you're like me,
I always find, I've had the privilege
of having several conversations
with Bill over the years
on things like education and equity,
and as I would have guessed,
he really cut through the issues,
I thought, in a very useful way.
So hopefully you enjoyed that.
Tomorrow, we're going to
continue the conversation.
We're going to have Fareed Zakaria.
I'm sure that conversation
will also get into a lot of
what's going on in the world,
and then on, let's see tomorrow,
and then on Thursday,
it's all a blur to me,
we're going to have, well, later this week
we're going to have Francis Ford Coppola
to talk about creativity
and probably things like narratives
and how to make sense
of the world as well.
So thanks everyone for joining,
and I look forward to seeing all of you
on future livestreams!